hi there steve kaufman here um i want to
do a video here about this whole subject
of
people correcting others
when they speak or when they're learning
a foreign language uh i have had two
videos recently one in spanish one in
english which touch on
this theme
in both cases i responded to people who
wanted to correct or
criticize my ability in speaking one or
other foreign language
i don't really you know it doesn't
bother me that people correct me
or criticize me when i speak another
language it's just that i'm not
interested you know it doesn't destroy
my confidence i happen to be very
confident
in speaking uh foreign languages and
even if i speak very poorly
it doesn't bother me that i speak poorly
uh i normally tend not to speak when i'm
at the early stages of learning a
language but if i run into someone as i
do occasionally say
who's a korean speaker even though i
don't claim to speak korean and i can
only stumble around in korean i'll say
some things in korean just for fun
i know that when i speak russian i
struggle very pretty badly i struggle in
italian that i haven't spoken for a long
time i certainly struggle in portuguese
and i'll still speak it and if people
criticize me it doesn't really bother me
but i don't want it i'm not looking for
it i'm not asking for it i don't need it
it doesn't interest me because i know
that i will in time improve
and very often i'm quite aware of the
mistakes that i'm making
now the discussions that we had uh
are there some of the comments to my
videos
were along the lines of a number of
people said well why are you so
sensitive and what are you you know what
are you afraid of people just trying to
help you should accept
the corrections but i i find that
corrections don't help
uh
i cannot while i'm trying to speak and
there's a fair amount of pressure on you
when you're trying to speak in a foreign
language already you're forgetting
things that in fact you know because if
you spoke to yourself in a monologue you
would remember a number of the words
that you can't remember when you're now
all of a sudden in a situation where you
have to remember them so there's enough
pressure
and uh i can't
you know basically
process the corrections and i know this
very well myself i i was today i was
having a discussion in english with
someone and i corrected because they
asked for it i corrected one of their uh
structures in in english they said
something like uh
you know i can't remember what they were
trying to say the more you do this the
more you know the more you
study the better you get or something
and they just couldn't get it they had
some
form that came from their language and i
said no we say the more you do this the
easier it becomes well the very next
time they said it they got it wrong
again
i think it's much better that i put
those
corrections in a report that the person
then downloads that's how we do it at
link
and they then integrate it they import
it into their system save those phrases
and hopefully start to notice that
phrase so that slowly it becomes a part
of their
of the phrases that they can use
one person commented uh you know when i
said i don't
want to be corrected i don't think it's
useful to be corrected and they said
well you've said that
the process of learning a second
language is very similar to the process
whereby a child learns his or her first
language the parents are always
correcting the child therefore wouldn't
it make sense for the adult learner also
to be corrected
well i have a number of problems with
that position
first of all the adult in fact is not a
child the child is used to being
corrected
you know
for you know
whatever naughty things the child does
the child is knows if they are in a
position vis-a-vis the parent that the
parent is allowed and will in fact
constantly correct them and tell them
what to do that's fine different with
adults we're not somebody's child
and i think the idea that the
relationships in a classroom are one of
a mother
telling her children what to do is not
i don't think a very good one certainly
once we're adult learners even when
we're younger
but but the other thing is i don't think
that parents correcting their children
in learning their native language i
don't think that has much influence at
all on how a child speaks
i think that some parents will correct
their children others do not
and all children end up speaking more or
less the same
so that i don't think it has any
any influence at all on on the child's
uh language or ability to speak the
native language correctly i think what
matters much much more is the experience
of the child in speaking with other
children
and possibly eventually at school
when they get into
you know higher levels if you want of
the language i think the child will
absorb a lot of words
from parents
and if the parents speak with the child
a lot and speak intelligently and treat
the child
as
you know a member of their conversation
not necessarily by correcting them at
every step but by including them in
their conversation that this will
encourage the child's language skills
and introduce the child to lots of words
and enrich their vocabulary so i think
that's a good thing to do but i think
correcting the child every time they
make a mistake in the language is
essentially useless because
the child
starts to pick up on certain patterns in
the language and starts to make some of
its own rules
so
you know if the past of walk is walked
and past of talk is talked
then the past of go is goad
so it's perfectly normal for the child
to say gold
and if you don't correct the child the
child will eventually figure out that is
went
and the correction by the parent is
essentially a waste of time
proof of that is that we have immigrant
children who arrive let's say in canada
as was the case with me i arrived at the
age of five
and i didn't learn english from my
parents
very often they were not in a position
to correct me although their english
wasn't bad
and i suspect there are lots of
immigrant children who arrive at the age
of three four five six seven whose
parents don't speak english at all
and yet if those kids go to school with
english-speaking kids they'll speak
english quite correctly very very
quickly
uh without the need for any correction
so the idea that the parents correct
them uh i think it's just simply
not true or at least it may be true for
some parents but it's quite irrelevant
the
most important thing in language
learning is the motivation and the
attitude of the learner
that the learner have positive feelings
towards the language and for the
experience of learning the language
there's increasing evidence and i don't
have it handy but i'm reading a book in
portuguese which means i don't
understand it a hundred percent but it
talks about our emotions and feelings
and so forth
damascus i think is i can't remember
but um
the whole process of learning involves
our emotions it's not something that's
done in isolation by some part of our
brain it's very much
you know
a part of how we respond to
to stimulus
and
and of course if we have good feelings
about something
uh positive feelings we're gonna do
better we're gonna feel better we're
gonna you know all kinds of positive
whatever chemicals charge around in our
brain so the big issue is to me
the correction does it make the learner
feel better that's the biggest issue of
all does it encourage the learner if a
learner is encouraged by a correction
then correct the learner and realize
though that it's not the substance of
your correction that's going to help the
learner but rather that that learner for
whatever reason is encouraged by
corrections it makes him happy or her
turns them on makes them feel positive
about the language but i suspect those
people are the minority i think a
majority of people
if they're trying to communicate with
someone and if they haven't asked to be
corrected
then for you to correct them is actually
disturbing because it tells them that
you are not interested in what they have
to say you are more interested in
correcting how they say it
whereas the person who's speaking in a
foreign language actually is more
interested in or should be in what they
have to communicate
so
i say again on the subject of
corrections unless you have the specific
a specific request from someone to
correct them
the permission
of the learner or non-native speaker you
should not correct them regardless of
the number of mistakes they make and
even when they ask you to correct them i
would be
i would go very carefully in terms of
correcting occasionally and far better
in writing than interrupting them when
they're speaking and that's why we send
reports after discussion that link and
we try not to too much correct people
while they're speaking so there you have
it that's my take on the subject of
correcting look forward to hearing from
you